how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU and today we have some awesome
Wan Division news it seems like a scene
from one division has been revealed and
when we combined this with some leaked
photos that we've gotten we actually
know quite a bit about this scene and
also at the same time we get a little
bit more insight on just what exactly is
happening in the 1 division series we've
seen the teaser trailer from Disney Plus
that shows us clips from the one
division series Loki and the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier and we saw many
different scenes in that teaser but this
new leaked scene kind of helps shine
some light on just what we can expect
from this series so we'll break it all
down in this video but first if you're
new be sure to subscribe to stay up to
date on everything or relating to the
MCU and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a black
panther Funko pop all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and leave a comment down
below so we have another leaked casting
call for the one division series
according to the stunt directory website
ice stunt a stunt double and Nicole
Redinger has been cast as the stunt
actress for a witch coven member in the
one division series now this is actually
a lot more important than it sounds this
actually links to a group of set photos
that were leaked not too long ago only a
few months ago and then these leaked
photos we see a bunch of different
witches together essentially a witch
coven so it appears that this stunt
double is going to be involved in this
scene and another major important part
here is that Catherine Hans character is
seen in this scene dressed up as a witch
basically confirming that she is in fact
Agatha Harkness now why is this
important well it's important for two
very big reasons well one is because
this scene is clearly not going to be
just a scene where the witches are
gathered together you don't hire or need
a stunt actress for a scene that is just
people talking this is somehow going to
end up as an action scene and we don't
exactly know who the stunt double is
going to be playing she could be playing
Wanda or she could be playing Agatha
Harkness or another witch but regardless
there's going to be some sort of a
battle between witches in this scene now
we can speculate on a ton of
things of what this could be and who it
could be but the most important part to
take away here is that this action scene
of witches involves Agatha Harkness and
that brings us to the second reason of
why this scene is so important
Agatha Harkness is going to play a huge
role in the one division series and she
is most likely the leader of this witch
coven that we see in these leaked photos
and right now what Marvel Studios has
described her as is the nosy neighbor of
Wanda and vision but it seems like we
know the real truth now especially after
seeing these leaked photos and seeing
her as a witch confirming that she will
be Agatha Harkness
and what this means is that all of these
different realities that we see Wanda in
in the teaser from Disney Plus all of
these different scenes all of these
different sitcoms that we see in the
background are most likely created and
caused by Agatha Harkness in the comics
Agatha plays a really big role with
Wanda she's a mentor to Wanda she helps
her develop her powers but she does also
end up manipulating Wanda a little bit
in the comics when Wanda loses her kids
to Mephisto in the comics Agatha
Harkness erases the memory of them from
her brain now this would eventually go
on to essentially caused her to snap and
lose it and in doing so she creates a
different reality and this is most
likely what we're seeing and the teaser
that we got for the one division series
but I actually think that it is Agatha
Harkness who is responsible for these
different realities and that would
explain why she's described as the nosy
neighbor in every different reality that
Wanda and vision will be in she'll be
there as the nosy neighbor no matter
what reality it is because she created
it as the leader of a witch coven she's
probably trying to get Wanda to join her
coven or at least control Wanda and use
her powers for her own will and what
better way to do that than to keep her
in a different reality or teach her how
to make her own realities so it looks
like Agatha Harkness is definitely going
to be the person behind these different
realities in the one division series and
apparently we are going to be getting
some sort of an action scene with her
and these other witches in the one
division series as well so give me your
best theory on what you think is
happening during this scene when all of
the witches are meeting together post
your theories down below in the
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU for live
updates you can always follow me on
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof